Some genres we watch because we expect a certain
amount of reality.
Historical dramas, biopics, and crime films
often draw heavily from real life events,
but when we go see a horror, comedy or action
film, we go to escape reality.
Yet you’d be surprised how often these seemingly
outlandish or unlikely films are inspired
by actual events.
Here Are 10 Movies You Didn’t Know Are Based
On True Stories
Indiana Jones
Spielberg didn’t choose Nazis for the baddies
in the Indiana Jones just because they’re
so easy to villainize.
Hitler was indeed obsessed with finding ancient
religious artifacts and spent a vast amount
of time and resources attempting to track
down relics like the Ark of the Covenant and
the Holy Grail.
Inspiration for the Indiana Jones character
has been accredited to several American archeologists
of the period, but another frequently cited
inspiration is explorer Roy Chapman Andrews.
Often photographed wearing an Indy-esqu fedora,
the globetrotting Andrews eventually became
the director of the American Museum of Natural
History.
Jaws
Just when you thought it was safe to go back
into the water, you watched a Screen Rant
video that told you that the attacks in Jaws
were eerily similar to a series of shark attacks
that rocked the resort town of Beach Haven
in the summer of 1916.
Novelist Peter Benchley updated these events
and based the Captain Quint character on Frank
Mundus, a shark fisherman who he spent some
time with while researching his book.
Mundus never met his demise at the jaws of
a great white, but actor Robert Shaw says
much of his memorable performance was indeed
based on the real life shark hunter.
The Exorcist
William Peter Blatty, author of The Exorcist,
didn’t just contrive this horror story out
of thin air.
There have been reports of demonic possessions
for centuries, but there was one in particular
that inspired the story of young Regan.
Blatty cites the 1949 exorcism of a 14 year
old boy in Maryland known only as "Roland
Doe".
Similarities between this case and the events
depicted in the film include levitating furniture,
violent outbursts, speaking in tongues and
an aversion to sacred objects.
After Roman Catholic Priests performed several
exorcisms, and sustained injuries from the
boy while doing so, Roland went on to live
a relatively normal life.
Goodfellas
Martin Scorsese’s 1990 film GoodFellas helped
define the modern gangster genre with its
dynamic structure and bursts of violence.
The characters portrayed by Ray Liotta, Robert
DeNiro and Joe Peci are so larger than life
that it’s hard to believe they were based
on real people.
Once gangster Henry Hill rolled on all his
friends and entered the witness protection
program, all bets were off and he filled in
writer Nicholas Pileggi with all the colorful
details.
Pileggi wrote the book that would become the
basis for Scorsese’s film.
If you want to know how accurate GoodFellas
was, you can listen to the DVD commentary
Henry Hill recorded on it before passing away
in 2012.
Silence Of The Lambs
For the serial killer Buffalo Bill in Silence
of the Lambs, writer Thomas Harris needed
look no further than notorious killer Ed Gein
for inspiration.
The things authorities discovered in Gein’s
home after arresting him were stranger than
anything a sane person could come up with.
They found furniture, silverware, and even
clothing made of human skin and body parts.
Like Buffalo Bill, he was stitching together
a suit of woman’s skin, some psychiatrists
thought this was so he could pretend to be
his mother.
Gein was also the inspiration for Norman Bates
in Psycho and Leatherface in Texas Chainsaw
Massacre.
Catch Me If You Can
How many people can claim to have been a lawyer,
a doctor, an airline pilot AND had Leonardo
DiCaprio play them in a movie?
Notorious forger and impostor Frank Abagnale
was never actually a lawyer, doctor, or pilot,
but Leo did play him in a 2002 film about
his exploits called Catch Me If You Can.
Abagnale assumed no less than eight different
identities which he used to pull scams all
over the world until he was caught in France.
At the time of his arrest he was only 21,
by 26 Abagnale was out of prison and working
to prevent the kinds of crimes he’d become
so good at.
His escapades as documented in the film and
book it was based on are so fanciful that
many still doubt their legitimacy.
The Sound of Music
If you trace back the many iterations of the
classic film The Sound of Music, you’ll
arrive at a memoir called The Story of the
Trapp Family Singers written by Maria Augusta
von Trapp.
The events surrounding her family fleeing
Nazi occupied Austria are not an obvious choice
for a family friendly musical so the film
took many liberties with Maria’s story.
They decided to concentrate on the love story
between the children’s nanny and their father,
even though that took place over a decade
before the Nazi’s rise to power.
And while they were a musical family, they
did not break into spontaneous song and dance
nearly as often as the film would have you
believe.
Almost Famous
Getting a gig writing for Rolling Stone and
going on the road with one of your favourite
bands sounds like every 1970s high schooler’s
fantasy.
But that’s exactly what future writer/ director
Cameron Crowe did when he lied about his age
to land a dream assignment with his favourite
magazine.
Almost Famous is the film that came out of
Crowe’s experiences travelling with bands
like Led Zeppelin, the Eagles, and Lynyrd
Skynyrd.
Much of this semi autobiographical film is
fictionalized, but losing his virginity, falling
in love and meeting his heroes were all things
that happened to Crowe during his time spent
on the road as an underage Rolling Stone journalist.
A Few Good Men
A Few Good Men began as a play written by
a then unknown writer named Aaron Sorkin who
got the idea from his sister.
She was a lawyer working with the Navy and
was going to the Guantanamo Bay Naval Base
to defend a group of Marines who almost killed
a fellow Marine in a hazing ordered by a superior
officer.
Yes, sadly “Code Red” is a real order.
The marines were acquitted but the film omitted
the fact that one of them was later murdered.
Apparently Sorkin thought audiences just couldn’t
handle the truth.
Star Wars
From gunslingers to nazis, the parallels between
Star Wars and Western history have been well
documented, but you should know that Lucas
also took a number of ideas from Eastern history,
particularly feudal Japan.
Take the Jedi, noble warriors who were basically
Samurai in space.
Both chosen from birth and trained their entire
lives to be thoughtful yet deadly peacekeepers,
the Jedi and Samurai even dress in a similar
manner.
Despite being powerful, their purpose is to
serve those in need of their services and
respect peace and order.
More overt references came in the form of
the Jedi’s weapon of choice and Vader’s
helmet, which resembles a Japanese Kabuto
helmet.
The Samurai were eventually replaced by a
more westernized military, and the knights
of old became the stuff of legends.
So there you have it.
If nothing else, this list proves that the
line between fact and fiction is easily blurred
once you get a couple creative people telling
the story.
What are some films you didn’t realize were
based on true stories?
Let us know in the comments below.